I'd like to get your reaction to What
Rand Paul pretty much the sole
Republican that that I know of who has
spoken out against the impending
Tick-Tock ban
I think we should be aware of those who
peddle fear I think we should be aware
of those who use fear to coax Americans
to relinquish our liberties to regulate
and limit our first amendment rights
every accusation of data Gathering
that's been attributed to tick tock
could also be attributed to domestic big
tech companies in fact one of the bills
they're looking at doing is Broad enough
that the president will be given the
power to designate whatever country he
sees fit to be an adversary and whatever
company underneath that definition it
would basically be a limitless Authority
for the president to ban speech before
Banning Tick-Tock these sensors might
want to discover that China already bans
tick tock
hmm we really want to emulate Chinese
speech bands aren't we the ones that say
it's wrong for China to ban speech so
we're going to be just like China and
banned speech we're afraid of I hope
Center Minds will reflect on which is
more dangerous videos of teenagers
dancing
or the precedent of the U.S government
Banning speech for me it's an easy
answer I will defend the Bill of Rights
against all comers even if need be from
members of my own party
what's your reaction to Rand Paul's
comments Taylor
yeah I mean exactly what he said it's
completely true like all of this stuff
about data privacy yes we have a huge
data project
before an adverse series want data on
you U.S citizens very easy to get
because literally we have almost no
privacy regulations so you know he's I
mean I basically agree with everything
he said
um he also you know I I do love the
prospect of you know the 2024 election
being like the Footloose election where
it is going to come down to politicians
who want to ban dancing on Tick Tock uh
versus people who don't want to I think
we know how that movie ends but
um Taylor let me ask you because you
also uh you know and and I'm assuming
you feel a little bit uncomfortable
being on the same side of something with
Rand Paul uh partly because you've
talked a lot about misinformation
disinformation Mal information on social
media platforms you are steadfast and
saying you know it's insane for the
government to ban Tick Tock it's insane
for the government to tell us what
social media platform or you know what
what kind of media we can consume and
for how long
what how do you go about policing you
know and these are contested uh
categories right of misinformation
disinformation Mal information how do
you go about policing that without
abrogating people's rights of
self-expression and freedom of speech
yeah well well it's always bizarre to me
when people accuse me of saying like oh
I want some sort of censorship because I
talk about misinformation never once
have I said that like the government
should be the one determining what's
misinformation or censoring anything on
social platforms I have always said I
think I I think misinformation and
disinformation look as journalists here
it's a huge problem it's very
frustrating people are grossly
misinformed on a lot of stuff because of
it the solution to that in my opinion is
better media literacy explaining to
people how these platforms work I mean I
always say the best way to debunk you
know of rumor and I've learned this
about rumors about myself right it's
it's it's not even to just say like
delete that right like get it taken down
it's to explain here's what's happening
right this person is lying here's why
they're lying here's the shape of this
campaign that it's taking right like I
just I think that the government does
not have a good track record on deciding
what's misinformation or not if they did
US reporters wouldn't have jobs jobs
right so you know
do you feel like
um you know kind of digital natives uh
you know and at this point I mean I
guess the the true generation that's
digitally native might be gen Z or
younger people but do you do you feel
like they are
um they're up to the challenge of that
kind of uh radical media literacy or
skepticism
um of you know of kind of vetting what
kinds of information they're they're
getting or are they even more kind of
prone to the sort of confirmation bias
that those of us who you know remember
the days of broadcast TV uh might be
yeah I mean look I think I think we have
a huge problem with media literacy in
this country across the board it's not
just Boomers it is also people on Tick
Tock I do believe everything they see on
Tick Tock and YouTube YouTube is a big
one that I hear all the time
um you know
are they up to the challenge maybe not
right now but they could be I mean I
think if we took this problem seriously
and if people in power took this problem
seriously we could have a better system
and we could have a more educated public
you know with a more diverse media
ecosystem by the way I'm a huge
proponent of independent journalism you
know journalists on social media people
getting their voices out not just these
Legacy systems
um and Legacy Media but
um but we need people in power to want
to do that and of course a lot of people
Empower their busy you know just
peddling their own brand of
misinformation so they don't really have
an interest in an educated public and
that's a huge problem that's been a
problem since even before social media I
mean I come I completely agree with
everything that you're saying there that
this this is the role of Journalism and
this is the challenge of our time is to
try to create an organic kind of uh
media literacy uh and like healthier
ecosystem but that's not what I've seen
unfold over the past say 5 five seven
years what I've seen is a concerted
political effort starting around 2016 to
create a perceived crisis around myths
and disinformation and I this is now
converging with the fears of China and
both of these things have like a root
truth to them but politicians are
running with both of these things to now
this is to now exert what what we're now
seeing as the most authoritarian version
of a Crackdown on a social media app but
we've been seeing it build up to this in
the ways that we've had these you know
kind of sketchy public-private
Partnerships in terms of policing myth
and disinformation online so do you
worry uh I mean do you agree I guess
that there has been that the kind of
feeding into that that perceived crisis
uh and and the idea that the government
needs to act on that crisis has kind of
created the conditions for what we're
now seeing unfold with tick tock
yeah I mean I think undeniably all of
these fears are playing into into this
Tick Tock stuff I think also these
lawmakers are being very Savvy in you
know touching on these lightning rod
issues that they know will instill fear
and panic
um I think it's just you know one thing
that I try and do with my reporting is
debunk things and and explain to people
how the internet works right and I don't
think that any of these lawmakers showed
very much understanding of how the basic
you know basic social media platforms
work how the internet works I mean the
Facebook hearings were equally as
painful this is not me just oh God they
were a national humiliation it was just
you know we need people in power that
understand these platforms intimately
and also are not just using them for
their own gain right like of course
they're going to use them to get elected
and stuff like that but but we need you
know people in power that aren't just
interested in their own power which is
very hard to find of course that's what
everyone in power just wants more power
but
um it's yeah it's disappointing to see
them rely on these these tropes and I do
think that you know debunking bad
information is important I think again
that's journalists do that every day and
there's ways that we can make a
healthier media climate that isn't
Banning apps or government crackdowns
that was an excerpt from reasons live
stream with the Washington Post Taylor
Lorenz if you want to watch another
excerpt from this live stream or the
whole thing go here and here
and come back every Thursday at 1 pm
Eastern Time to Reasons YouTube channel
and watch this live and participate ask
questions and we'll we'll get answers
for you thanks for watching